foreign
the best thing to do is ignore it
previously on TV since sending it
previously on of something they already
sent previously on TV since ignoring
death threats is dumb keeping your phone
this close to the sink do you know how
nasty sinks are and that's before we
even talk about how waterproof it is or
getting knocked to the floor there's a
shelf right there under the mirror and a
flat surface over here by the wipes you
may be indestructible Jen but your phone
certainly isn't look if you aren't going
to run a vent fan or something to keep
your mirror from steaming up do not use
your hand to wipe it off are you drunk
in a late night College frat party in
the 1960s because all you're going to
end up doing is streaking
hey I've seen that trick on Tick Tock
Disney's really going all in on these
funky fresh edits huh also shutting the
door to get changed when you're the only
one home acting like you're the one that
invented the terrible idea of Dipping
fries and milkshakes that's right I said
terrible I see you salty sweet people
you've all clearly lost your minds
drive-in theaters for when the only
thing you thought the movie going
experience was missing was the smell of
gasoline in a cacophony of random engine
noises oh no we're really doing the
cliche Jen gets clingy out of nowhere
and obsesses over a guy not texting her
backstory line uh for the love of Jeri
Ryan this episode is seven of nine and
we still haven't seen Daredevil
sometimes this show is like one of those
timeshare presentations where you have
to stay until the very end to find out
if your wasted time was worth the
mystery gift and the costume designer
said can we give Nikki a scarf with a
bow so big it makes her look like her
head is a Christmas present and then
someone else was like yes why can't he
just text me back why is that so hard
sex pressure is real then the idea that
anyone owes you a text response is part
of the reason we all deal with more
relational anxiety than ever before
there was a day not too long ago where
when you were in the same room you had
conversations and when you left you just
stopped existing until the next time you
saw each other so give people a break if
they don't want to be available 24 7
okay
not giving the great Muppet Caper your
entire attention also who cut out the
part where the other inmates tell Miss
Piggy to go for it before she bent the
bars this is the kind of Studio
interference that neuters great art not
closing your blinds on a Sunday morning
this is not a decision a normal human
makes this is a decision a gaffer makes
we don't have the resources for a squad
of uniforms to go with me hold up you're
the parole officer for a previous big
bad in a Marvel movie and they didn't
assign extra resources to cover the
possibility that he might transform into
Abomination into a repeat of Brooklyn
that seems highly unlikely I figured my
chances of staying out of the ICU would
be much greater if I had a Hulk there
with me you do remember the collateral
damage Hulk's cause right Bruce sent his
share of loved ones to the ICU including
his girlfriend Betty at the start of the
movie if your goal is to stay out of the
ICU maybe pursue a different form of
employment and stay away from Hulks and
their enemies completely look at how
close these three cars are parked to
each other there is no way the middle
car parallel parked here so either this
guy's an or this guy's an
and I'm sending both just to be
safe we so you haven't sent a follow-up
text in the last three days either
you're granted at least one follow-up
text before you start to sound desperate
especially after 24 hours you could even
start a new hey how's your day otherwise
you might be the one inadvertently
ghosting them because they somehow
missed your one message distracted
driving just because you'd survive a car
crash by turning into She-Hulk doesn't
mean whoever you hit would walk away
unscathed put on my green screen yeah
get big Jolly bring yourself I don't
know what you call it hulking out okay
good whatever then would you please yeah
but not on camera or in any way that
would make us have to pay for more
special effects than we already have to
do in this episode but it was worth it
because my favorite chicken
princess silk feather was stuck playing
favorites even with chickens it's
harmful you're supposed to love all your
babies equally do you know what happens
when one sibling discovers their brother
or sister is the favorite they grow up
bitter join a YouTube channel where they
spend their days nitpicking movies and
TV shows you wouldn't want to send your
chicken to such an awful fate would you
Emil I have recalibrated your inhibitor
and she is good to go didn't Bruce
Banner invent the inhibitor wouldn't
take someone of his intellect to
recalibrate it or do all California
parole officers have doctoral degrees in
biochem Tech at the very least shouldn't
someone from The Avengers or shelled or
swar to be out here to help it's
it's in a safe environment that
environment of course being the exact
time you were leaving for plot reasons
so much unnecessary backstory that
wasn't really backstory Jen that was an
explanation of an actual current
processing of trauma I mean I agree I
could have also done without this man
but I would have fourth walled
more accurately I can't drive this how
am I supposed to go home now are you
sure it's undrivable you didn't even pop
the hood or try starting it and if a
dented Hood cracked windshield and
smoking engine prevented someone from
driving I wouldn't have made it to
school every day in my 94 Dodge Neon God
rested soul my name is Dan Bull not
mechanical bull they didn't ask you to
repair the vehicle they asked you to
push it which has nothing to do with
being a mechanic yeah that felt very far
admitting your jokes are in a
ceremonial sweat yet we integrate the
past and the present into one being
earns not the actual structures just the
word makes me think of yogurt which
makes me think of yoga wait if you do
yoga in a yurt would you call it yogurt
what you want me to leave after my
terrible yoga pun no mistake clearly
you're not in a teachable mood right now
she didn't ask you a teacher bro I
understand you want to help but you need
to wait for someone to ask first it's
like when Nami kept telling Luffy to
leave her Island during the arlong park
Saga she kept throwing dirt at him
demanding he leave her alone as she
cried he patiently waited until she
realized how badly she needed his help
and only after she asked for assistance
did he provide it man I wish I was
watching One Piece instead of She-Hulk
right now considering you've already
pounded the no service part of the
situation into our brains do we really
need the extra visual aid here she's
holding up her phone or the full minute
you spend on this unfunny gag to force
the plot forward
oh hell yeah entering a room without
knocking to announce yourself I'm just
gonna work over here in the one square
meter of this property that actually has
reception square meter square meter you
take that back where I'm throwing you in
the sweatshirt and cranking up the
temperature to 45 degrees Celsius but
also this appears to be sort of a
superhero anonymous group but everyone's
cool to just keep sharing their
with someone else in the room now also
also she will immediately move away from
this single 10.76 square feet of space
and sit on the couch remember how we
talked about vulnerability and how
important it is to the process you're
just going to be in an old guilla and
mambles issues to bounce to a separate
problem that's not really how A group
therapy session works I'm starting to
question your abilities to run a retreat
center that aids others in processing
their identity issues how taking your
suit off would be great first step title
and complete content of my sex
instructional pamphlet
hey sorry I'm late I I lost track of
time of the year interrupting what's
supposed to be a private and safe space
to discuss sensitive mental health
issues by shouting have some tact
wrecker that guy's here you probably
don't even remember who he is I don't
previously on this guy this is not one
of the guys you were previously on so
this is misleading at best
you did not stack them you lined them up
stack implies a pile and none of these
chairs were on top of each other words
mean things man bull I'm not getting my
kicks and I'm fine while Jen might
benefit from working through some
emotional issues downplaying the fear
and anger she carries as a result of
being attacked in a dark alley by four
men with magic weapons isn't a positive
way to address her problems I'm starting
to suspect that the show that can't
lawyer also might struggle with mental
health thing I want people across the
room into perfectly stacked chairs
perfectly stacked you left an entire two
feet or so between these chairs in the
wall man bull that's a waste of space
and that's before we even get to the
uneven distribution between the two rows
hey getting a little worried just want
to know you're okay blushing smile look
I once texted a friend goodbye and they
immediately called because they were
worried I was in a car accident and
laying in a ditch somewhere and using my
last remaining energy to text them
goodbye I'm just saying this doesn't
seem that bad like you think life would
be so much easier if I were that person
the dad but he's never
[Music]
all right screw this guy she already did
sheesh pay attention you're gonna miss
important plot points and sound like
you're Oh my beat start box is ready to
be opened delete Josh's number is what
he said what the guy could be kidnapped
and trapped in a basement somewhere and
you're just gonna delete his number hell
the dude could just need a few days of
space for some personal business just
because the show has the Josh's evil
bomb in the chamber doesn't mean anyone
here should know that yet I will never
forget any of you honestly that's funny
because I already have whoa whoa whoa
that was not the same way she pulled him
sexily into the room the first time we
saw it we saw the same moment earlier
she grabbed his shirt all super sexy
like and dragged him in and now she's
just grabbing his arm is this a clue
does it mean something is Josh a secret
scroll is Reed Richards messing with
time to Galactus create an alternate
reality sorry guys I'm just really ready
for phase four to be over
[Music]
you kept the flash on while you're
trying to be sticky Josh is a terrible
spy oh no not the blood chemical thumbs
up emoji combo is She Hulk ending
why aren't you calling me I can't
imagine you calling me on a Sunday's
good news Donuts is there anything they
can't do I know exactly who I am my name
is
do I look like a mechanic my name is Van
Bull and I'm a mechanical bull
joke so I realized real strength comes
from facing yourself in the mirror and
saying I'm good enough
I'm smart enough and doggone it people
like me how many hours a day have you
been wearing that mask Papa this is the
way delete it delete it delete it delete
it delete it